jorge lopez from puerto rico former
second round pick by the brewers back in
2011 he was dfa in august the orioles
picked him up and right into the fire
ronald acuna jr the 22 year old
superstar who's in the batter's box
ellie strikes out of cuna to kick off
his knight
that's a wonderful way to start off your
night well the braves have spread out
defensively behind tukey tucson gotta
pound the strike zone tonight as you
said not a great hitting team don't give
them free passes
so two on and nobody out in the first
inning against tucson left-handed band
of dj stewart he's in there
ready with two strikes and the pitch
he got it 95 mile an hour fastball
perfectly placed now double play gets
him out of the inning here is ryan mount
castle the oriole dh mount castle having
a terrific year 347 415 on base and
eight extra base hits in 21 games four
doubles and four home runs
he laces this one in the left that is
down for a base knock mullins set around
bro will go into third ryan mount castle
an rbi single and the orioles take a
one-nothing lead let's find out with
this 2-2 pitch
it's on the ground left side riley can't
get it dansby did
he's going to throw toward the plate and
the braves have a rundown
[Applause]
iglesias
chugging slips and falls and finally the
tag is applied and the braves get a
break as the orioles run themselves out
of
the bottom of the first inning in the
middle of the atlanta order darno
swanson nick marchakis
and the o2 fastball
called strike three on the outside edge
swanson made a terrific play
to end the bottom of the first
and a strikeout for jorge lopez that is
number three he's picked up they're two
on with nobody out i've got a deal with
stewart who's got six home runs in his
last eight games
arie swings drives one high deep right
field back mark cake is this one out of
here
three run homer for dj stewart it's
number seven on the season and dj
babe stewart goes deep
again now mount castle swings belts one
is center field acuna back at the wall
he runs out of room back to back home
runs stewart in mount castle orioles
with a five-nothing lane in the third
my oh my remember when the orioles
couldn't score any runs not too long ago
no problem so far tonight
fifth home run of the year
for the 23 year old ryan mount castle
who's d.h tonight a three-run homer from
stuart solo's shot from mount castle and
they are loaded up for mullins
there's his swing line drive into right
that's a base hit one run scores hayes
coming to the plate throw is cut off
orioles keep things going in the bottom
of the third inning it's a two-run
single for cedric mullins and the
orioles latest 7-nothing runners on the
corners two away
nothing orioles for jose iglesias
jackson kicks 2-0 pitch iglesia swings
and this ball is climbing climbing
and is it fair yes
jose iglesias the orioles don't know how
to hit anything but home runs right now
three run shot jose iglesias breaks open
the ball game it's 10 nothing orioles
bottom of the third jose iglesias is
coming to the plate next three run a
homer
as he swings and flares this one into
shallow right down for a single hayes
jogs around he scores jose iglesias it's
another rbi for him and the orioles lead
stretches to 11 nothing one and nothing
against stewart
this one is
deep and short left
safe stewart legs it out and velazquez
comes down to score with another run
braves will go on the phone see if they
should ask the umpires to take a look at
this
no he's safe i'm just wondering why
albies is not covering second base
because that was the only play for
dansky to go all the way across the
diamond he had to go in the hole he was
shifted over too you didn't think he was
going to get dj stewart that is close
but i think stewart is in there but
because of that the innings still alive
for mount castle
[Applause]
it's this one pass riley and into left
field
here comes
iglesias
he's in there safely
add another rbi to mount castle's night
he's driven in three
and the orioles lead
is 13
nothing top of the sixth inning freddie
freeman will lead off he has one of the
braves three hits tonight ozzy albies
has the other two
and freddie shoots one deep in the air
toward right center field at the track
and wall freddie freeman has spoiled the
shutout bid
with a long home run
freddie freeman's 11th homer of the year
gives the braves something to cheer
about it's now 13-1 we know malaysia he
can move all around the diamond
and hit some home runs too i mean just
96 97 at bats last year with cotarotti
that one caroms off the glove of
marcaikus and it's a home run he gets
one in the seventh why not add another
one it's off the glove of marques and
over the wall 14 to one orioles
so now here comes rylan
one more round
out to center mullins got it
cedric mullins
closes out the game in style
and the orioles take it 14-1
over the atlanta braves
orioles get nine runs in the third
season high 14 runs in the game
and cedric mullins with another
tremendous catch